tengo
[Música]
sí
en dakar nuestros observadores se
movilizan por la educación la ecología o
el empleo en el centro de sus
preocupaciones está la juventud de
senegal en esta nueva edición de línea
directa nos muestran sus acciones
concretas en el día a día
es una ciudad en el extremo occidental
de áfrica la capital de un país con una
economía dinámica que sueña con estar
entre los líderes del continente en
plena transformación dakar es también
una ciudad joven en senegal más de la
mitad de la población aún no ha cumplido
los 20 años estos jóvenes construirán el
senegal de mañana y tendrán que hacerse
cargo de cuestiones fundamentales como
la educación la ecología o el empleo
estos son los temas que movilizan a
nuestros tres observadores en dakar
abductores agricultor urbano
mandiá
y locutor de radio y mahamadou que acate
profesor
ah
hola chicos tenemos tres aulas que
arreglar así que vamos a empezar con
esta
seguimos el mismo procedimiento raspar
para quitar los defectos vamos a
preparar la pintura manos a la obra
mamado un conocido como su unión es
profesor pero también pasan gran parte
de su tiempo libre en los colegios de
dakar junto con su equipo de voluntarios
remodelan colegios que a menudo están
completamente deteriorados como esta
escuela primaria en el centro de la
capital el proyecto nació un poco por
casualidad en 2020 cuando nuestro
observador decidió limpiar algunos
colegios antes de su reapertura tras la
primera ola de kobe 19
nos dimos cuenta de que los colegios que
limpiamos no estaban en buenas
condiciones volvimos a la escuela donde
empecé la primaria en 1995 y los baños
eran los mismos por la noche hice una
publicación les pedí a mis amigos que me
ayudaran a conseguir el material que
necesitaba al día siguiente vi que la
publicación había sido compartida 250
veces y que un donante había decidido
financiar todas otras escuelas nos
llamaron por la noche para decirnos
vengan a ayudarnos no hemos parado desde
ese día
el proyecto funciona inicialmente con
financiamiento colectivo y en aras de la
transparencia todas las facturas se
publican en las redes sociales
donde en su mayoría renovamos las aulas
los baños y los comedores intentamos
tener un impacto en la seguridad y la
comodidad de estos niños pero también y
sobre todo en los resultados sabemos que
si un niño está en el entorno ideal de
comodidad y seguridad podrá aprender
bien y tener buenas notas en el futuro
aquí están los baños para mí los baños
son realmente lo más importante en un
colegio
durante su periodo menstrual muchas
niñas se quedan en casa porque no tienen
baños funcionales en todas las escuelas
en las que hemos puesto baños
funcionales las niñas vienen a estudiar
les va bien
en dos años mamadou diabaté y su
asociación team nietzsche se han hecho
un nombre en senegal han renovado 23
escuelas y han recaudado más de 150 mil
euros ahora los proyectos son
financiados por compañías como esta
empresa de limpieza pero acabado insiste
en que no reciben nada no más que sus
voluntarios la recompensa está en otra
parte
el equipo mente es más que una
asociación es una familia conoces gente
nueva aprendes cosas nuevas no podemos
esperar siempre a que el estado o el
gobierno hagan algo porque no lo hacen
así que creo que depende de nosotros
implicarnos
en un día se renovarán los baños y tres
aulas de la institución
en 2020 de las aulas de esta gran
escuela secundaria del distrito de geoff
fueron reformadas con urgencia para
poder organizar los exámenes de
secundaria para la directora era
necesario recurrir a mamadou
nos dimos cuenta de que escribíamos
muchas cartas a las que no les daban
respuestas simplemente por la lentitud
de la administración me dirigí a mi
jerarquía es decir a la expectorada de
la academia y fue ella quien recurrió a
los servicios de juniors de acá de la
academia prefiere recurrir a los
ciudadanos voluntarios pero ellos
tampoco pueden hacerlo todo dos años
después de las obras los tejados que
fueron instalados ya están siendo
devorados por la erosión el océano está
cerca en las aulas que no pudieron ser
renovadas las situaciones peores
aquí se pueden ver el cielo cuando se
dan las clases así que no hay seguridad
ni comodidad el edificio tiene que ser
demolido y reconstruido
la respuesta del ministro de educación
es que cada año se abren nuevas escuelas
y que estas son funcionales invoca la
demografía para justificar la situación
actual
cada año tenemos casi 450 nuevos alumnos
de 1º de primaria como cada clase tiene
unos 30 alumnos se ve la dimensión de
esta cifra ha calculado el número de
aulas necesarias
calculado el número de profesores
necesarios han calculado el número de
materiales didácticos y pedagógicos que
se necesitan hay cosas que no podemos
hacer porque estamos en un sistema que
es un poco lento hay procedimientos que
seguir
como el estado no puede hacerlo todo lo
hacemos nosotros por la comunidad y por
el bien de nuestro país nos gustaría
expandirnos y motivar a otras personas
para que hagan lo mismo que nosotros
todos senegal y áfrica
[Música]
por favor miren por todos lados no dejen
nada incluso los paquetes pequeños son
importantes debemos limpiarlo todo
estoy cansada porque hay demasiada
basura
tenemos que hacerlo porque si no lo
hacemos durante el invierno las
alcantarillas se atascarán y eso no es
normal no es normal la gente no sabe
nada de salud y eso me enfada
y
yo me llamo avtur e inicia el desafío
distrito verde hoy es el día mundial del
medio ambiente y reunía mi comunidad
gracias a la ayuda del barrio y de la
escuela para iniciarnos en una pequeña
actividad de limpieza y reforestación
plantación decoración del barrio
se pone la tierra abajo y después se
echa la arena así
a touré se ha convertido en una
referencia en materia medioambiental en
su barrio tacumbú en 2019 anunció un
hashtag que pretende inculcar un
comportamiento respetuoso con el medio
ambiente en una ciudad que se desmorona
bajo los residuos y se queda sin aire en
dakar el nivel de partículas finas es de
2.5 veces superior al recomendado por la
organización mundial de la salud
la iniciativa desafío distrito verde
comenzó aquí frente a mi casa un día me
di cuenta de que había mucha basura
decidí poner mi teléfono en un trípode
grabar en cámara rápida y compartirlo en
las redes sociales para animar a la
gente a pensar en su entorno abdul touré
le transmitió a sus vecinos incluso a
los más jóvenes las acciones de sentido
común su calle es ahora una de las más
limpias y verdes de dakar es especial lo
principal es que cada ciudadano
senegalés tome conciencia de su ambiente
y de su entorno no pierdo la esperanza
creo que dentro de cierto tiempo en 25
años tendremos una dakar verde muy
limpia porque la ecología no es
necesariamente algo occidental pero la
gran fuerza de nuestro observador es que
ha creado una verdadera comunidad en
línea el desafío del barrio verde se ha
extendido a más de 15 países africanos
para que la calle y sobre todo la
terraza de aptur la que ha inspirado a
sus admiradores
acá cultivo verduras plantas aromáticas
fugas y especias
lo que es interesante ecológicamente es
ver este ambiente ventilado sano antes
y si tuviéramos la mitad de dakar con
balcones verdes o terrazas verdes sería
realmente maravilloso porque desde el
punto de vista ecológico es una
regeneración del ecosistema
traerá muchas abejas y pájaros creará
otros tipos de interacción entre
animales e insectos de interacción
mostré las hermosas fotos de la terraza
y muchas personas se interesaron en eso
y me preguntaron si podían utilizar el
desafío distrito verde en sus países en
costa de marfil chad togo ghana como
horas la gente lo está apropiando en su
contexto en mauritania se hacen muchas
sesiones en las escuelas y sobre la
reforestación
en costa de marfil están mucho más
interesados en la gestión de los
residuos plásticos compartimos toda la
información de los 15 países miembros
todos los embajadores de los 15 países
miembros están ahí y también hay un
grupo especial el del desafío senegal
verde hacemos este tipo de cosas para
motivarnos y apoyarnos mutuamente porque
sabemos que no podemos esperar todo del
estado cada uno hace lo que quiera con
el hashtag pero lo principal es como
siempre digo es impactar positivamente
su comunidad conmigo
el activismo de abdul y ganó el interés
de un programa de radio seguido por
miles de senegaleses los jóvenes tienen
la palabra conducido por nuestro tercer
observador en dakar mandiá festival y el
hecho de que viniera a encontrarse con a
future el mismo día fue una pura
coincidencia
pero
no
hoy los jóvenes tienen la palabra con
motivo del día del medio ambiente va a
tratar de entender cómo las personas los
niños se implican actualmente en el
ambiente que has aprendido hoy lo que
estás haciendo
todos podemos este es nuestro barrio y
esto es en senegal cuando compro algo me
lo como y luego lo tiro si es normal en
absoluto
ha sido escuchado
desde 2011 mandé hp jim ha llevado su
emisora móvil por todo senegal para
hablar de temas como la salud sexual y
la violencia el programa los jóvenes
tienen la palabra es transmitido en
línea en las radios comunitarias y tiene
un espacio en una importante radio
privada este verano pretende presentar a
100 jóvenes que sean exitosos en la
agricultura como vocal que se hizo cargo
de una granja a una hora de dakar sainz
jr network es una joven promesa que
queremos presentarle al mundo para
inspirar a otros jóvenes interesados
agricultura lugar es ingeniero agrónomo
y puso su experiencia al servicio de
esta granja que ahora produce cebollas y
papaya durante 10 meses del año frente a
los tres meses de antes este desarrollo
abre perspectivas para los jóvenes de la
zona
la gente que vive en mi barrio viene a
trabajar cuando hay huelgas en la
escuela durante las vacaciones vienen
aquí a trabajar a ganar les pago a
diario luego regresan a sus casas y así
pueden comprar útiles escolares bebidas
y todo eso yo creo que la agricultura es
el único sector que puede absorber
extraordinaria tasa de desempleo que
existe actualmente en áfrica
especialmente en senegal el gobierno
debe centrarse en las acciones para el
desarrollo de la agricultura para que la
gente pueda entender que la agricultura
tiene un potencial real al resolver el
problema del desempleo al igual que
mandir le dio una mano a abocar nuestros
tres observadores están creando
vocaciones personas del equipo de mamá
tus diakhaté se han formado en la
industria de la construcción y
admiradores de abductores lanzaron su
microempresa de agricultura urbana en un
país en el que casi una cuarta parte de
la población está afectada por el
desempleo los iniciativas son gestos
para ayudar a los jóvenes a incorporarse
al mundo laboral